Long live France!
Go from Marseille and Provence who came here
kick off this campaign
Europeandeux-mille-vingt-quatre,
rich in time,
in promise for our activists.
To be built
is jerked off
our identity by 1 immigration of massive settlement,
there is a lot to do.
So uh.
It is normal that it is always Marseille.
I think they understood everything.
Me, Marseille,
we are a little in distress,
while before I continued to be lived
in two thousand and eleven,
it was good
now
because the city of Marseille is shared,
uh
alas with uh.
There is too much immigration and the time it stops,
totally uncontrolled immigration
that changes the Phocaean city
as it changes many neighborhoods in France.
Marseille is the big city that votes the most for
Marine Le Pen,
the most for the National Rally
at each election in a way of being with the family.
It is the 2nd city of the 2nd city of France
and for 1 1 much of the alternation,
it's logical to launch
uh.
This campaign in 1 big city of France.
And it is 1 big city that has eliminated some
problems.
And these few
problems are not solved because they have caused,
that is,
neither the left,
nor the Macronists who today co-manage Marseille,
one to scale uh
municipal,
the other nationally.
So this is 1 way for Marine and Jordan
to show the importance it attaches
to this great city
of France which suffers but which could,
who could, very quickly.
Resurrect with political will,
two-three 5,
6,
7.